Kentucky has become ground zero for the
abortion debate its sole remaining
abortion clinic is under threat and the
state could become the first in the
nation without an abortion provider
hundreds of protesters from a national
anti-abortion group are gathering there
this week they are making the state and
that clinic their target and her
Werner's in Louisville where she's been
talking to the clinic's director and
those who want to shut it down and a
good morning good morning Gail and what
you're looking at here this black and
yellow tape on the sidewalk this is a
buffer zone it was put into place by a
federal judge late last week because
back in May protesters actually blocked
patients access into this abortion
clinic now what the protesters have been
doing is lining up right along the edge
talking to patients as they go in their
goal is to shut this clinic down
[Music]
abortion opponents started gathering at
churches in Louisville over the weekend
gearing up for citywide protests
evangelical activist Jason storms and
wife Sarah brought their eight children
with them from Milwaukee along with a
firm belief we have the wholesale
legalized protected tax subsidized
killing a little human beings in the
womb is to me just it is deplorable the
group he belongs to operation save
America calls Roe versus Wade a covenant
with death and wants to close down the
clinic the last remaining abortion
provider in the state this is exactly
why this matters Kentucky's abortion
landscape is changing Republican
governor Matt Bevin publicly opposes
abortion and the GOP controlled
legislature has passed new restrictions
on abortion in May nearly a dozen
protesters were arrested for blocking
patients access to the clinic storm says
they plan to be peaceful this time well
they're certainly not committing
violence on anybody on our side one of
their activists told me that they don't
espouse violence do you believe that no
Anahola has been the clinic's director
for 17 years how do you feel about being
a target it's a fancy because these
people outside believe that they have
monopoly over gone and they don't
understand that he is in here too you
got this everywhere you know those
people outside on
the only Christians in the world so the
u.s. marshals are here to help keep the
peace
today also later today a federal judge
is going to decide whether to issue an
injunction to keep this buffer zone in
place for a longer period of time but
protestors don't just plan to be here
they plan to go to the clinic doctors
homes as well Jeff Anna Werner thank you
very much